many of you wrote To Me
and you said David sir I'm a big strong
guy but I have tears in my eyes as those
stories often go because as I looked
through this gay marriage bill that just
passed
it's not really clear that it actually
guarantees gay marriage
and those people are absolutely correct
absolutely correct and so I want to talk
about that the reporting widespread from
over the weekend and late last week Bill
to protect same-sex marriage rights
clears Congress the idea here was let's
codify gay marriage before maybe
Republicans come for it and the Supreme
Court makes a decision on gay marriage
like they did with Roe v Wade we have
seen many on the right say the gay
marriage decision was just as wrongly
decided by a prior Supreme Court as was
Roe v Wade making it clear they are
setting their sights and targeting gay
marriage as well as a whole but access
to contraception and other things as
well so the idea was let's codify it
let's guarantee gay marriage and indeed
the house on Thursday is the New York
Times rights gave final approval to
legislation to mandate Federal
recognition for same-sex marriages hmm
that's interesting what does that mean
the vote was 258 to 169 with one member
voting present this now goes to Joe
Biden who will of course sign it I don't
want to sort of like sugar coat this or
dance around it the legislation doesn't
require states to issue marriage
licenses for same-sex couples that is
not what the legislation does
States currently have to do that because
of the 2015 decision from the Supreme
Court
if that decision were overturned even
despite this legislation
States would no longer have to issue
same-sex marriages what the law says is
that states that uh that all states
must recognize same-sex marriages that
were entered into someplace else so let
me give you the exact scenario imagine
now that gay marriage has been codified
even though it hasn't really now that
this law has passed imagine that in a
year or in two years or whenever there
is a case that gets to the Supreme Court
much like the case that ultimately
overturned Roe v Wade gets to the
Supreme Court and the Supreme Court does
decide hey it was wrongly decided it was
wrongly decided so we're doing away with
the 2015 decision that uh made game that
banned bans on same-sex marriage does
this new law mean that if Kentucky
doesn't want to anymore they have to
enter issue same-sex marriage licenses
no it doesn't
all this law says is that if the 2015
gay marriage decision is overturned
Kentucky would have to recognize
same-sex marriages from wherever so you
wouldn't be able to deny a gay couple
married elsewhere all of the same rights
that married people have in Kentucky but
it does not mean that Kentucky would
have to issue same-sex marriage licenses
if the 2015 decision is overturned so
it's better than nothing but at the same
time
if people don't have money to travel in
order to get married somewhere else it's
going to create problems it's going to
create problems for people it doesn't
guarantee gay marriage to anyone it
guarantees if you find a place to get
married
it will have to be a recognized marriage
in all 50 states and again this is all
preemptive it's if the 2015 decision
were to be overturned that is what it
does
and that is what it does not do is it
better than nothing of course it is is
it not really that great if the issue is
let's make sure that no matter what
happens gay and lesbian couples will
continue be being able to get married in
any state yeah it doesn't do that it
absolutely doesn't do that it is what it
is important to understand it now we
know what it is and we press forward
we'll take a quick break and be right
back you know how tough it can be to
navigate the online news constantly
being thrown at us and that's why I love
our sponsor ground news which is an app
and website that allows you to easily
compare how any individual story is
being covered by different sources every
story comes with a bias bar showing the
distribution of reporting from Left
Right and center you can flip through
the headlines to see how a word or a
detail completely changes the
interpretation of a story
you can even see each news Outlet's
parent Corporation so I can distinguish
between independent and corporate owned
sources right now I'm looking at a story
about Iran helping Russia build drones
for Ukraine and I can see it was covered
by 35 sources 17 are government owned
like RT and Ukrainian media
interestingly it looks like the majority
of the coverage is coming from the
center and the right making it a
potential blind spot for the left go to
ground dot News slash Pacman try it for
free or subscribe to get unlimited
access to all of their news analysis
tools the link is down below